nvidia's top of the line rtx 30
90.
no no there's no time for that
we've got to talk about this thing now
if you haven't watched our rtx 3080
review here's the background you need
rtx 3000 also known as ampere is what
nvidia is calling the biggest
generational leap in performance in the
company's history now if you go back far
enough i'ma press x here
but he's also not joking these cards
unlike the touring based rtx 2000 series
are smoking fast right out of the gate
with our rtx 3080 reaching speeds in the
neighborhood of 75 to 100
faster than its predecessor depending on
the task
that combined with nvidia's super
impressive dlss 2.0 upscaling technology
means that 4k gaming went from
someday to
today
right now
but wait there's even more like this
message from our sponsor team group team
group's extreme argb ddr4 gaming memory
features clock speeds up to 4000
megahertz and a stunning mirror design
with rgb check it out on their launch
event showing off their three brands and
you can run a 3 000 pc at the link below
but the 3080 is last week's news in my
hands right now is what jensen ceo of
nvidia lovingly referred to as
the bfgpu
and spoiler alert he's right
this is an rtx titan for scale heck
here's an rod strix oc for scale this
thing is easily the largest not to
mention heaviest conventional graphics
card that i have ever seen which means
that anyone who buys one needs to also
make some additional investments
first up you're gonna need a case with a
solid gpu mount and enough clearance
being both taller and thicker than
previous flagships it simply won't fit
in most small form factor cases
that is unless you hot rod them
second you will need a fat power supply
rated at
350 watts of power consumption and with
nvidia's new 12 pin connector the 3090
could easily push your previous unit to
its limits
last but not least you're going to need
the fastest gaming cpu in the world
because quite frankly with anything else
you are going to be leaving performance
on the table which is
something you don't want to do when
you're paying 1500 us dollars for a
graphics card yes my friends compared to
the rtx 3080 the world's first 8k gaming
gpu gets you more than double not to
mention faster video memory 20 more cuda
tensor and rt cores and
even nv link support via a new connector
that was presumably shrunk to minimize
wasted space on the physically cut down
pcb that makes nvidia's new flow-through
cooler possible but wait
double the video memory
why
well
aside from giving it much better compute
capabilities and more importantly the
ability to render much more complex 3d
scenes in software like blender as it
turns out gaming at 8k also genuinely
demands this much video memory i mean
think about it ak is 33 megapixels at 32
bits per pixel
that means to display just a single
frame
128 megabytes of video memory is needed
which doesn't sound so bad but add in
textures models screen space effects and
of course
rtx real time ray tracing i mean come on
and you've got yourself many times that
ideally 60 times per second or more
wolfenstein youngblood clocked in at
over 11 gigs of memory usage at 8k
sounds fun but at the end of the day it
all boils down to performance doesn't it
so by request we built up a core i9
10900k test bench to minimize our cpu
bottlenecks and dug out our rtx 3080
along with a 2080 ti and titan rtx for
comparison starting off with minecraft
rtx we're seeing about a 22 average
frame rate improvement over the rtx 3080
and a whopping 51 to 60 percent over the
titan rtx both with the lss on and off
not bad
wolfenstein youngblood meanwhile gives
us a much more modest performance
improvement over the 3080 at around 15
but while still pulling off a
respectable 50 improvement over the
titan rtx a card that costs a thousand
dollars more
so there you have it guys
buy yourself an rtx 3090 and a water
bottle with all that money you saved am
i right lttstore.com csgo and microsoft
flight simulator tell a very similar
story in 4k
but interestingly the gap narrows
significantly for flight simulator at
1440p because of cpu bottlenecks
that's right despite the op cpu and
ultra graphic settings
finally the parallel n64 emulator which
does most of the graphics and sound
emulation on the gpu rather than the cpu
and recently added upscaling support
shows us that the extra oomph brings us
up to 99th percentile frame times near
60 fps
that eight times upscale by the way
works out to more pixels than 5k
emulated
but then
there's the elephant in the room
8k gaming
as tom's hardware reported nvidia's
demos only showed 8k aaa gaming with
dlss 2.0 in what they're calling
ultra performance mode now before dlss
2.0 offered performance and quality
scaling options with performance
rendering at 1080p like the lss 1.0 and
quality rendering at 1440p before
upscaling usually to 4k
now
ultra performance still uses 1440p
but instead of performing a reasonable
scaling jump up to 4k
it's trying to take that data and go all
the way up to 8k i mean
that's a lot of guesses to make in terms
of hmm what are those smeary pixels
so does it look any good
well on a 4k display there's little
point in using it since the only real
effect is similar to anti-aliasing which
can be had with less performance penalty
in other ways
but if you are one of the privileged few
with an 8k display today
here are some shots of what you can
expect to see from 4k native versus 8k
dlss ultra performance versus 8k native
you can see clearly that 8k dlss ultra
performance delivers significantly more
detail than 4k does
even if it isn't quite up to 8k native
standards i mean check out the text and
distant details in this shop for example
8k dlss ends up much closer to 8k native
here even if it's still not perfect
and the same deal with these grates on
the floor in this shot they're almost
completely wiped out in 4k but dlss
restores that now performance is roughly
25 less than 4k but
that still puts us above the magic 60
fps mark on average which is pretty
sweet if you shelled out for one of
those new 8k tvs with hdmi 2.1
even better is that not every game even
aaa games necessarily needs to use dlss
we ran do maternal at native ak
with very high detail settings for what
was honestly the most mind-bending
experience i've had with this gpu so far
and we barely saw dips below 60 fps also
impressive during that session with the
88 inch tv was hdr gameplay recording
with shadowplay now we had wanted to
include a big section about performance
and image quality but the story is sort
of already in the footage that you're
looking at it
just worked the performance hit was
reasonable and it looks as good as you
could expect given the 100 megabit per
second bit rate at such a massive
resolution
our entire 8k gaming experience video
yesterday was shot with it running in
the background without any hiccups
whatsoever
great job
productivity though is where the rtx
3090 both gets to stretch its legs and
also
get a little bit dicey
going up against the titan and blender
we saw anywhere from a 50 improvement
with the cpu optimized gooseberry render
all the way up past 100 more performance
in the pavilion barcelona optics render
yes my friends gooseberry a benchmark
designed for cpus can run on all of
these cards thanks to their ridiculous
amounts of vram
other rendering benchmarks like v-ray
redshift and octane bench all provide
similar numbers across the board with
the rtx 3090 hovering around the
15 to 20 percent mark over the 3080 and
50 to 80 percent over the titan
then there's spec you perf where we can
see that the rtx 3090 is
sorry wait what no no go back to that
katia ran over 40 faster on the titan
how does that make sense okay so as it
turns out
this card while it has more raw
hutzpah than the titan rtx and was
introduced as if it were a titan-ish
it isn't a titan when we spoke to nvidia
they explained that there are driver
optimizations for the titan that have
not been enabled for the rtx 3090 and
presumably won't and they confirmed that
these results are 100 expected behavior
which
kind of sucks because if this thing is
mostly just
a giant overgrown
3080 ti at 1500
what's the ampere titan going to cost
three grand anyway
back to spec view perf we did get
several wins for both the rtx 3090 and
the titan rtx depending on the workload
with siemens nx not even being in the
same area code let alone ballpark that's
kind of rough for professionals who are
looking to juice up their workstation
for cad work by day and gaming at 8k by
night
which do they choose
and there's more bad news remember that
bit about needing a new power supply
well our test bench sure did even a high
quality 850 watt couldn't keep up with
our rtx 3090 routinely breaking
375 watts with nvidia's pcap power meter
connected throughout our testing with a
peak power draw of over
450 watts
the titan rtx meanwhile barely broke 300
watts the whole time
thankfully the cooler as with the rtx
3080 was well up to the task and it
didn't even break a sweat through spec
view perf with thermals never pushing
past 70 degrees also core clocks were
ridiculously stable at around 2
gigahertz under load so i guess all that
weight and metal is doing its job and
then some nvidia was clearly really
concerned with thermals this time around
and
they just did a great job there's no
other way of putting it and hopefully
that means some overclocking headroom as
well early reports on the rtx 3080
seemed to suggest that the gddr 6x
memory is pretty easily bumped up but
we've also seen reports that nvidia went
for lower speed ram due to thermal
limitations so
as always stress test your overclocks
with a prolonged load before considering
them tournament ready and speaking of
overclocking we have a video coming
where we look at the differences between
aftermarket gpus so make sure you get
subscribed so you don't miss it
for now
these results leave me i mean there's no
real word for it other than conflicted
about the rtx 3090 on the one hand it's
a beast of a graphics card
but on the other hand
it's clear that nvidia is holding it
back so they don't eat into their titan
or quadro lineups
kind of like how intel runs things with
xeon
it runs really cool with a fan that's
not nearly as loud as the rtx 2000
series but it guzzles power and i can't
help feeling like a doofus for buying it
for workstation or cad use knowing that
there could be a titan coming down the
line
that puts the 3090 squarely in prosumer
slash enthusiast territory so like super
high-end gamers content creators and
especially 3d modelers are going to love
it which isn't a bad thing
it's just
a niche thing and i can't help but feel
that nvidia could have done more to make
the 3090 shine
do you think that's fair
anthony
do you think that's fair yeah
how about you jensen
i know you watch our videos
and i also know that you don't like it
when you think i'm not being fair which
is kind of funny to me because
i get to sit here imagining a man who
casually buys 40 billion companies and
changes computing as we know it who
still gets butt hurt when some nobody
youtuber doesn't like his gaming widget
enough
but on the other hand
you know what jensen
i actually really like that about you
it's that kind of passion that makes
nvidia so great
so i've resolved
to keep making you mad because evidently
when you got mad that i didn't like your
rtx 2080 ti
we got the 30 80.
so i might go even harder on you guys
just to see how far you can push pc
gaming
no i'm just kidding jensen
sort of since i have your attention
please unlock the titan driver paths and
sri ov at least for the rtx 3090 this is
a niche enthusiast card and it should
really enjoy niche enthusiast features
don't you think
just like our viewers enjoy my segways
to sponsors like
privacy and one password two services
that prioritize security and convenience
starting now privacy users can
automatically add their virtual cards
into their one password vault with a
single click and one password users will
be able to create virtual cards in their
browser and store them in one password
when creating a new virtual card with
one password users can set a spending
cap and adjust settings for a one-off
payment monthly or annual limits or a
total amount users can limit cards so
they can only be used at a single
service to help keep things locked down
and when it's time to enter payment
details one password will show users any
cards associated with that website
including any privacy cards you've
generated so head to privacy.com linus
and sign up for an account new privacy
customers will automatically get five
dollars to spend on their first purchase
or if you're a new one password user
head to the link below to also receive
five dollars when signing up
good stuff
so thanks for watching guys if you're
looking for something else to watch go
check out our review of the rtx 3080
where we happen to use a ryzen bench
instead of an intel bench does it
perform better with pcie gen 4
i'll see you over there